- Do you remember the first time
you ever performed anywhere,
like when you were a kid?
- Yeah, I remember the
first time singing live.
I had this teacher at
school called Mr. Wren,
and I idolized him
and I wanted to be like him.
He was the kind of teacher
that all the guy teachers wanted to be
and all the girl teachers
wanted to be with,
that kind of guy, you know.
If we're lucky in our lives,
we all have that one person that sees us.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he saw me and he sang
and I wanted to be just like him.
So he would--
- That's so cool.
- So I started singing.
Then he would encourage me to sing
and he'd put me on stage to
sing a song by Johnny Nash
at the Parents and Teachers
Association evening.
Now, my parents had never
heard me sing before.
They didn't even know that I sang.
And I remember him calling
my name to the stage, he said
"And now, we're gonna have Young Seal
and he's gonna sing
this Johnny Nash song."
I can see clearly.
- Yeah.
♪ I can see clearly
now, the rain is gone ♪
♪ It's gonna be a bright, bright ♪
♪ Sunshiney day ♪
- Such a great song.
Yeah.
- So he goes.
- Feel free to do that at any
moment during this interview.
It sounds so sexy.
It's so cool.
It is, your rasp, I like.
You know what it is, when I'm
tired, like I'm tired today,
but when I'm tired, I love
singing when I'm tired
'cause I feel like I
can sound cool like you
or I'm like maybe Tony Braxton.
You have that low raspy just like, mm.
I don't have that most of the time.
Keep going, so sorry.
How did you do with the
song when you were a kid?
Were you nervous on the stage then?
- Well, yeah, I was.
I remember him calling me
and it's like that scene in a movie
where everything goes silent
and you can hear a pin drop.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And 'cause it was acapella
and no one had ever heard me
sing before, so I remember.
- You didn't even sing with
music for the first time?
- No, no.
It was just.
- [Kelly] Bold.
- So he called me on stage
and I remember standing there
and looking out, and seeing
everyone in the audience
just pretty much like I'm seeing you
except there were more of you.
And I just, I wanted
the stage to just open
and swallow me up, you know?
- [Kelly] So nervous.
- It was the last place I wanted to be,
and I was kind of like I was frozen,
but somehow I closed my
eyes and got through it,
and sang, and kept my eyes
closed at the end of it.
And then just everyone applauded,
and I remember looking up
and seeing my parents going.
- Like "What?"
- And the interesting
thing about that experience
is that that place, that stage
that felt like the most terrifying,
most lonely place all of
a sudden felt like home.
And I never forgot that feeling.
So, I guess throughout my life,
I did different things
until I eventually decided
I was gonna commit to singing.
But I never forgot that feeling.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I always knew that
I would come back to that.
- I love that story, but I
also love that you pointed out
it is like, if one person
sees you when you're younger
and it gives you confidence
like that you can do something
and maybe you're special
and every kid likes to
feel special, right?
- Yeah, of course.
- It does take one person,
I think to like, I mean,
it's good if it's more than one,
but if it's just one, that's nice
that you feel like you
maybe found something
that you're special at and it gives that,
that's what happened to me too.
- And it really, and you
are absolutely right.
- It changes your personality, everything.
- Yeah, it really comes
down to who, you know,
that champion or those
champions in your life
that do see you and
encourage you to be special.
- Yeah.
- And who knows, if not for Mr. Wren,
perhaps, you know, it
wouldn't have happened for me.
I certainly wouldn't
have had that experience.
And throughout my life,
I've had timely people who
have come and championed me
and have seen me in different ways
and given me the inspiration
and the courage to move on,
which is why I feel so
strongly about mentoring.
- Yeah.
- I found out fairly recently
that as much as I love singing
and as much as I love performing
and as much as music is a part of my life,
I really love coaching.
I really love, I would much rather
see somebody else transcend
- Yeah.
- Whatever's holding them
back than doing it myself.
I get more pleasure out of that.
- That's why I love being
a part of "The Voice."
Yeah, 'cause it's like everybody
and especially 'cause I
came from that environment,
like it's the most awesome
thing to be blessed
in your career.
A lot of people can sing, a lot
of people can do what we do.
Don't have your tone, but like, you know,
a lot of people can do what we do,
and it's cool to be able to
like look at someone younger
and go, "Let me show you
what maybe you're not seeing,
that little light in you."
And it's so cool to be able
to bring that out of people.
It is so gratifying.